ragazzi allora poi vedete molto spesso
quella mia divisa di gucci
ma oggi gucci ma che nulla perché oggi
come sapete tutti
esce merchandising di fa vj online lo
potete ordinare il mio merchandising da
oggi me lo vedrete vestire perché come
potete vedere il merchandising fa vj ti
rende veramente figo
perché chi non vorrebbe innanzitutto la
scritta fa vj sul prezzo
quindi da oggi me la vedrete in tutti i
video non quasi tutti perché alcuni
locali o registrati prima ma i video che
registrò da oggi in avanti avranno tutti
la mia felpa chi non ha la mia felpa fa
schifo e come potete vedere la felpa
rende belli fighi seri persone vere
persone che hanno un futuro che meritano
un futuro guardate che roba
guardate il portamento guardate come la
felpa ti rende unico e supereroe
incredibile ragazzi merchandising fa vj
chi non lo è uno sfigato e oggi in
questo video vi farò vedere come sono
andato allo shooting per fare appunto la
promo al mio merchandising foto che
andranno queste ovviamente sul sito dove
verrà venduto il merchandising oltre che
ai miei 20 live e alle fiere perché le
fiere eventi rari ci sono i miei salemi
e felpe mia marchandising dotato online
e lync m in descrizione che sarà il mio
sito dove prendere le magliette e le
felpe chi al merchandising fa vj e figo
come jean pierre e adesso vi faccio
vedere lo shooting bella
siano di lastre vieni vieni giuliani
anche tu
fatic anima viva cammisa all isee
inferiore ai 50 delle famiglie sulla
torre per questo guardare per questo
smalto dai bravissimo è pronto a tifare
inter di tenere traccia molli 3 dammi un
bit
io sono tornato questore al mercato io
sono gli hacker fino a titone gestito da
chi non mi muovo devi di riuscire a
togliermi la mano ma non così vittoria
ma la nasa sta emettendo è stato
bravissimo
il suo dimenticato la geografia grazie
non mi ricordo anche piccolo inizia
quando devia la polizia laggiù fi steel
am3 festival azionati 1 giu
mettiamola giù ma sei pazzo grazie
magari fatto 7 levati 5 aia mi va bene
mi vesti anche non faccio io faccio io
impariamo a tirare pre con la mela
faldini libri pazzo
[Musica]
un attore non potrei fare se li guarda
madonna mi sento veramente ai polmoni a
mio favore 0 spanò amore mio
vai a giocare i videogiochi non fare
come lo tocca
questa è una cosa stranissima
ragazzi questa dal backstage dello
shooting è adesso ci sarà un contest che
lancio adesso che esce il no
merchandising vj chi vincerà a questo
contest avrà la maglietta e la hbo la
felpa autografata fa vigente per
scoprire come vincerlo guardate il resto
del ciao io sono quello che fa i video
oggi dopo tre anni
apro il merchandise nelle magliette che
lo so merchandising il merchandising e
quando tu fai le magliette con il suo
logo la cosa basilare che tutti youtuber
fanno ancora prima di avere aperto il
canale di youtube oggi per inaugurare il
merchandising ufficiale fa vj tv che
ufficiale non quello che ben bancarelle
quelle che sa quelli quello non c'entra
niente altra roba il merchandising
ufficiale ufficiale la parola ufficiale
deve essere il nuovo trend 19 fi jtv è
quello che trovate sul sito che vi
lascio tra l'altro in descrizione oppure
negli eventi ufficiali dove ci sono
anche io che faccio foto eccetera ci
sono anche le mie magliette quali sono
gli ufficiali tutto il resto no visto
che da una vita che me lo chiedete di
aprire cinesi ce l'abbiamo fatta
ho deciso di fare una roba un po
speciale ho deciso di firmare un po di
magliette visto che ce ne sono che ce ne
sono adesso mi metto qua e il firmerò le
prime le prime magliette del
merchandising e chi avrà la fortuna di
beccare la mia firma avrà la fortuna di
beccare la mia firma pressione firma
tutti quanti ha detto che ognuna ci
scrive un po dedica un po carina perché
sono dopo le prime quindi sono i primi
esemplari
partiamo piace un sacco questa cosa
delle magliette anche perché ci abbiamo
messo meschini e questo potrebbe essere
un problema
comunque no questa cosa delle maglietta
mi piace tantissimo perché ci abbiamo
messo una vita per scegliere il prodotto
migliore la qualità migliore roba che
tutti i marchi via
era questa la prima maglietta ciao
adoranti di fa vige il primo che troverà
la maglietta è sempre una scelta alla
tutte le cose che indossi anche le calze
permesso non magliette quindi per me
questa è una maglietta o sguardi ballata
maglia
una maglietta di farli j questa felpa
che ho firmato e la prima che posso che
potete trovare ed è quella colloso
standard perché ovviamente queste sono
lo colloco standard hanno tra l'altro
per riconoscerle l'etichetta se
l'etichetta fa vj che la cosa number one
del mondo questo è il logo standard
questo è l'uomo nero
ok
e se firme anche scrivi tappa vj a te ci
hai visto limonato no dai
scrivo un saluto blu anche i blu mai è
male aspirava ciao io ho detto niente
quindi ragazzi
queste sono le prime 40 che abbiamo
stampato che spediremo randomicamente
insomma insieme a tutte collegate
andremo a vedere quindi se prendete le
magliette adesso avrete la possibilità
che riescano una di queste randomica
quindi ragazzi
vado a ringu starle di orde di persona
via col resto del video quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato
veramente veramente perché per me è un
orgoglio vestire il mio marchio che da
adesso in avanti diventerà quello che
sovrasterà bucci e tutto il resto da
domani tutte le persone al mondo aver si
vestiranno fa vj perché fa vige ti ti ti
fa godere ti rende unico niente spero
che ho visto che sia piaciuto ragazzi
trovate le magliette in fiera trovate
nel link in descrizione che sarà il link
dove prenderebbe maglietta online se
volete da oggi cercherò di vestire
appunto il mio brand se in alcuni video
non lo vedete perché magari o registrati
prima ma oggi vestirò fa vigenti come i
figli se noi avessimo vissuto ragazzi ci
diano prossimo video lasciato un momento
mi piace anche per i suoi cerchi minuto
de ski se non solo ci si chiede al cda
dal possibile 0
[Musica]